je trouve ma part de tous les morts font
maintenant c'est trop mais il faut il
faut ces produits c'est là que j'ai
vraiment compris que cet enfant sans que
vous connaissez la suite
bonjour les amis cette semaine je suis
très heureuse de vous inviter avec moi
de l'auxois voilà là bas il ya une
tradition autour du travail du fer qui
dure et qui perdure et j'étais curieuse
de savoir comment ce travail
cette tradition de la métallurgie à la
haute précision d'aujourd'hui pouvaient
traverser les époques et bien j'ai eu
quelques réponses avec de belles
personnes alors je propose de me suivre
c'est ici c'est maintenant c'est là
[Musique]
look soit entre dijon et le morvan est
une succession de vallées et de vallons
sillonné de rivière c'est un territoire
rural ou deux puis légaux loin on
travaille le verre les forces de
l'abbaye de fontenay celle de buffon
était à leur époque aussi innovante que
la métal valley de vous
[Musique]
j'avais envie de revoir le geste
emblématique de cette industrie et la
couleur du métal façonné pierre marc et
forgeron sculpteur et poète ici
[Musique]
on
les deux derniers coups de martin
bonjour pierre mah jong un qu'est-ce que
tu es en train de faire alors je réalise
une étude là pour un projet de feuillage
est alors justement j'allais attaquer
les nervures pourvoir se seraient donné
tu vas pouvoir maintenir la feuille
comment je vais réaliser la fin je pense
sans risque prend leur sage droit qui
pense avec bien sûr parce qu'il ya quand
même la chaleur
bon le métal font mille quatre cent
cinquante degrés mais en général on le
travaille entre 1300 1350 tu le mets
bien à plat et vous voilà très très bien
et là je vais réaliser les rêves et puis
là on va faire les nervures en travers
pour donner de la vie à la famille voilà
[Musique]
j'imagine que pas même temps imparti
pour faire ça pour les 8es oui c'est
toujours le combat contre la chaleur
parce que plus le métal est chaud plus
il est souple et puis il est facile à
travailler
naturellement il est hors de question de
chercher les outils quand le faire
échouer
et c'est de là que dire expression
battre le fer pendant qu'il est chaud
je vais te donner des protections il a
vécu il a déjà vu des sirènes je te
garantis c'est mieux comme ça je vais
tâcher d'en
mitchell on peut dresser
ça peut paraître un métier brutal un peu
bourru on peut et on peut dire oui le
forgeron le bûcheron on s'aperçoit
qu'après que la maîtrise on rentre dans
le domaine artistique en affine on
s'intéresse alors on s'intéresse à ce
que nos anciens nous ont laissés
concernant les beaux projets comme l'art
nouveau brandt des gens comme ça alors
on trouvera notre vraie valeur
moi il me faut un défi que je sois
capable de conduire le métal là où je
veux que j'ai une maîtrise sur lui
physiquement faut que je sois y trouver
de façon il ya des fois j'arrive à la
fin des 10 cultures il est temps que ça
s'arrête là je viens de faire un
escargot de 350 kg j'ai voulu faire le
taureau parce que ce que je n'étais la
porte c'est la force j'ai voulu faire un
charolais était en fait les choses en
dévier et j'ai peut-être voulu exprimer
le côté rebelle
ce côté fonceur
libre et ce qui fait que ça a fini par
un taureau de combat en masse sollicité
pour un projet et ça va se passer à
montbard les forges de buffon je dois y
aller je dois y aller
voyons tout le palmarès de buffon tout
ce qu'il a pu étudier les j'ai pas eu de
difficulté à trouver un sujet donc j'ai
proposé de réaliser un chêne le chêne de
bourgogne il y aura les glands des
nervures sur le bois il y aura les
glands tu peux montre une curieuse quand
même de voir si c'est si dur que sa robe
bien sûr le moi j'ai pas tes muscles la
taille n'est sûrement pas sa force
c'est trop dit l'otan sont pas originaux
ouais
[Musique]
ouais pierre marc merci merci merci donc
bay coûte on a tout un chêne à
bourguignon affaire de temps au travail
et puis moi je vais voir ce que ça donne
voilà peut-être l'endroit où tu exposera
dako très possible et à bientôt vont
retour salutaire marois pierre marqué
son projet m'amener là où la forge
moderne et l'industrie avait pris
naissance en auxois buffon dont georges
louis leclerc pris le nom et les forges
que le naturaliste installa sur ses
terres près d'un cours d'eau et des
gisements faire
sa fortune lui permet de poursuivre ici
ses recherches en physique et en
cosmologie tout en concevant une
manufacture moderne une des premières
usines intégrées mais fond on le connaît
quand même avant tout comme naturaliste
et la majorité des gens ne connaissent
pas le buffon métallurgistes finalement
est en effet buffon a quant à elle été
important dans la métallurgie parce que
c'est un des premiers à avoir fabriqué à
ce qu'on appelle un complexe intégré
c'est ici le complexe et difficile voilà
ça veut dire que tout est sur place tout
donc la fabrication dû faire toutes les
étapes
et puis la vie quotidienne des forgerons
ce que l'objectif de buffon c'est
d'avoir la main d'oeuvre sur place mais
aussi un vivier de futurs forgeant ainsi
tous les enfants qui n'y c'est ici
travailler avec leur mère d'un potager
et les garçons dès qu'ils avaient 12 ans
va quitter leur mère pour rejoindre leur
père à la forge et devenir à leur tour
forgeron on imagine ici devant la grille
les gens qui allaient qui venait il faut
même l'imaginer plus plus bruyante que
de nouvelles menaces très champêtre et
bucolique c'est très agréable au 18e
s'était même pas tellement caste une
vraie cour d' usine dès qu'on ait fait
des allers et venues de chariots j'ai du
bruit
une centaine de personne ne nous dit
rien qui vivait ici entre la forge
logement le potager donc c'était
vraiment petite place du village
tout ce qui se passait ici ce qui est
rien comparé à l'activité qui avait dans
la forge qui donc de l'autre côté
nous voilà donc dans le haut fourneau
c'était vraiment le coeur de la forme et
du coup buffon a tout mis en scène parce
que ici on était vraiment au spectacle
voyez il ya les deux balcons oui les
invités de buffon des notes de marc
prenait place sur ses balcons pour
assister en contrebas à la coulée de
fonte en fusion c'était vraiment le
spectacle c'est là où il ya le haut
fourneau qui se trouvait derrière la
maçonnerie et c'est par là qu'on charge
est le minerai de fer et le charbon de
bois est donc au bout de douze heures de
fusion à 1200-1300 degré on obtenait de
la force et au bout de ses douze heures
on va effectuer une coulée de fonte en
fusion qui s'est effectuée en contrebas
a même sur le sol dans un moule de sable
ça devait être compétent spectaculaire
depuis dans des conditions absolument
d'une des enfants faisait très chaud il
faisait très sombre aussi le sens
d'efforts l'apport il y avait tout le
bruit des marteaux donc c'était nadu
atmosphère très impressionnant
finalement ce savoir-faire matérialise
le début de l'industrie à propos en
parler a complètement oui parce qu'en
fait là on est dans le premier atelier
on trouve y en a trois donc c'est une
succession des ateliers donc tout a été
conçu pour optimiser le travail du fer
pour travailler le plus vite possible et
le plus possible donc là en 1768 du
fonds annonce complètement des avionnais
clé d'industrialisation buffon trace une
dérivation de 600 m pour apporter à l'
usine low de l'armançon tout proche
la forme de proue de bateau des
bâtiments divise le bien-fonds trois
canaux qui font tourner jusqu'à this 9
roue à aubes ce sont les moteurs des
marteaux pilons de la frange
[Musique]
buffon dont lui doit d'avoir créé
finalement le début de l'industrie
d'avoir mis en un seul lieu justement
toutes les étapes pour fabriquer c'était
plus dispatcher comme avant à tel
endroit en fonction des ressources
là il avait l'endroit idéal où tout
était à portée de main donc d'en faire
tout en un seul lieu de trois en un
en maître de forges précurseur de la
révolution industrielle buffon ou un
matérialiste du siècle des lumières
en tout cas il ne serait pas surpris
mais plutôt intrigués par les usines
ultramodernes de mon bas et sans doute
peuple fier de visiter le musée qui lui
est consacré
c'est là que je me suis rendu pour
comprendre buffon et le chemin parcouru
par la science depuis le xviiie siècle
car à cette époque les sciences se
résumait à une collection de curiosité
mais après tout ça peut mener loin la
curiosité
voici l'oeuvre de toute une vie les
trente six volumes de l'histoire
naturelle de buffon ou justement dans le
siècle des lumières buffon va commencer
à décrire la nature dans sa globalité
c'est ça un naturaliste au siècle des
lumières c'est comprendre la nature à
travers les mammifères à travers l'homme
à travers les oiseaux à travers le
mouvement des planètes
et c'est à cette époque là finalement
qu'on va commencer à mettre les animaux
dans des cases à les nommer à
rationaliser la science des sciences
naturelles
alors là c'est le texte peut-être le
plus important de buffon c'est la
théorie de la terre dans laquelle il va
être le premier à dire de manière
expérimentale que la terre est beaucoup
plus ancienne que ce que dit la bible et
ça c'est génial au xviiie siècle dans un
siècle extrêmement religieux de pouvoir
écrire et imprimer plusieurs centaines
d'exemplaires que la terre à 74 milles
en plus de 74 millions et comment buffon
le prouver il le prouve dans les forges
de buffon avec ses petits boules et en
différents métaux en différentes
matières qui va chauffer à blanc et il
va calculer le temps de refroidissement
de ces boules et comment il refroidit on
n'a pas de thermomètre au xviiie siècle
il demande à des jeunes femmes de
toucher le boulet et quand le boulet
n'est plus trop chaud et considère que
le métal s'est refroidie il considère
aussi que la terre c'est un noyau avec
plein de différentes matières que la
terre est une petite partie du soleil
qui est en train de se refroidir et il
extrapole pour savoir combien de temps
cette terre amie se refroidir
[Musique]
c'est le cabinet de travail ou buffon a
historiquement rédiger les trente six
volumes de l'histoire naturelle
générales et particulières
c'est un lieu qui a peu changé depuis le
xviiie siècle puisqu'on voit encore au
mur les estampes aquarelles et des
oiseaux qui sont peut-être le
chef-d'oeuvre de l'histoire naturelle
qui est du fond a confié à françois
nicolas martinet les 1008 estampes
aquarelles et qui donne une image
incroyable de la nature et puis
d'oiseaux qu'on ne connaissait pas
encore au xviiie siècle ou lui envoyer
partout des spécimens et buffon les
décrivez et puis il écrivait
paisiblement ici dans son cabinet de
travail et ce qui est étonnant c'est que
de nos jours encore on peut voir par la
fenêtre une nature complètement
préservée et puis un peu plus loin les
usines métallurgiques qui sont
finalement les héritières de la grande
forge de buffon
la métallurgie en auxois ce n'est pas
seulement mon bas en 2011
un des fleurons de la métal valley est
sorti de terre à 15km bon mais là on
change totalement d'univers
on reste dans le faire ici dans l'auxois
mais là c'est high tech et oui même si
les tubes qu'on fabrique ici sont
destinés à ces journées très très basse
le niveau de la mer
ces deux hautes technologies qu'ils
sachent industries pétrolières oblige
imaginez des cordons ombilicaux
métallique tressé ensemble et dont
chacun depuis la plateforme va alimenter
en eau en gaz en huile ou en fibres les
installations de forage offshore à 10 km
de profondeur pas facile de réparer un
cas de défaut les tubes doivent donc
résister à la pression à la corrosion et
autant la fabrication doit en être
minutieuse et les contrôles nombreux
l'excellence de lusine de venarey les
laumes
en fait la première au monde pour ce
type de technologie
sur le produit fini ça donne sens et
youtube ont roulé sur une bobine on peut
aller jusqu'à 30 40 km de tube clients
on va faire tout en contrôle dont des
sous qui se soit l'été sur youtube le
diamètre
si elle a des fours à l'intérieur du
tube dans la matière ou en fait sont
détruits il ya 100 % de la surface du
sud qui définit ici
alors 3d vraiment parce que une fois de
pub sort d'ici il a semblé en week-end
et il va passer au moins 20 enfants de
la mer sans possibilité de changer de le
maintenir ou permettent à l'eau quand on
va avoir une machine avec des d'y aller
qui va déformer le paya rend très rares
ou épuisés et les deux faces revenir
dessoudé sont d'abord deux machines donc
on à laser fondé de passe derrière on a
un système qui va laminer de l'intérieur
quand on fait une soudure
on a toujours un petit décor extérieur
est dedans le dessus c'est saint pol pot
lire des bouquins collines et
l'intérieur une machine qui va laminer
et donc on va voir un film sud est qui
va ressembler un tube son fils derrière
on a des machines des calibres eux donc
leur venait tranquillement le cube au
diamètre final est donc ici on est sur
la partie contrôle non destructif dans
la différence machines de contrôle est
là en terme de tolérance est extrêmement
serré on va travailler à 5%
c'est à dire que sur un puck qui va
faire 2 mm dp on a droit à plus ou moins
1 10 viennent un dixième un show donc le
tube s'est plus ou moins un cheveu c'est
bon au dessus d'un cheveu ces poubelles
mancebo se présente christophe
en fait donc qui est aussi là depuis
2011 où le réel de la vie
il a l'expérience et notre référent est
aujourd'hui la réalité de cette ligne de
production quelques spécifications de
travail
bah moi en fait je suis capable de gérer
la ligne complète donc après par rapport
aux contrôles non destructifs toute la
partie réglages toute recherche de
d'efforts qui siège avec c'est
intéressant et vincent qu'ils ont
rejoint les papiers montant est
justement de l'apprentissage des
contrôles non destructifs dans
l'alternance entre notre usine est ici
professionnelle de mon livre
l'étudiante fois pourquoi tu as choisi
ce bois c'est là précisément 12 août à
un précieux par parler des polars des
bougies
les matières scientifiques et
technologiques
[Musique]
c'est à dire que prendre le marteau et
taper à l'enclume
non je le fais je la fais c'est
nécessaire de le faire pour en arriver
là
oui c'est mieux vaut et le but et après
de travailler ici
ah ouais c'est clair c'est mieux lorsque
des métiers très technique
les formations sont très longues sur le
groupe prologue est requis pour être
certifié il faut 2 lillois au poste pour
pouvoir passer
quels sont donc ces très bons termes de
formation on a besoin de gens assez
technique
on était douze ya un an on les plus de
50 aujourd'hui bravo
on a recruté usines en france en
bourgogne en côte d'or à
venarey-les-laumes et dont le siège est
belle
nous sommes en marche et ça marche eric
venais de me présenter en alternant en
formation au lycée eugène guillaume de
montbard
c'est vrai qu'on y prépare entre autres
si diplôme liés à l'industrie comme si
l'établissement faisait partie
intégrante de la métal valley synchrone
avec les besoins de l'industrie locale
je devais aller voir ça de plus près
excusez moi bonjour monsieur bernardo où
vous êtes en train de faire quoi
l'emprunt de discuter sur l'avenir des
deux élèves 2000 à elle ce sera de
l'alternance elle veut faire
l'alternance
donc elle cherche une entreprise on en
discute et mladen lui va faire la suite
d'un bac pro mei mei maintenance des
équipements industriels
tu vas te diriger vers quoi avec ça je
me dirige vers une mention
complémentaire qui est le cndd et le
cndc le contrôle audition quelles
qualités ça exige bonnaire des contrôles
il faut être sérieux faut être attentif
et le monde de l'entreprise tout quand
qu'intégrer bientôt oui j'ai un autre il
ya notamment présent dans roth
elle est loin des civils dans les zones
oggi ça c'est un bon point aussi
j'imagine
et toi ludmilla en fait avant j'étais en
général donc j'ai fait une première s
enlise scientifique voilà je suis posé
la question mais qu'est ce que je vais
faire et j'ai trouvé un bts melons donc
maintenant ce qui m'intéressait bien je
te dis ça c'est pour moi c'est un peu
ouais un peu et comment pourquoi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais en fait
je connaissais un peu de jeunesse
enfin ce monde parce que j'ai du côté de
la famille que tes pairs ils sont un peu
tous dans le domaine donc des petites je
connaissais un peu
l'entrepôt mon grand-père d'avc machine
ces odeurs d'imaginer sa femme réveillée
donc je me suis dis bah oui c'est ce que
j'aime faire tout ça que je suis ni scié
super tu dois avec la seule fille ou une
des seules oui c'est pas pénible ça
et votre parcours à vous mais c'est
bernardo mais moi je fais mes études au
lycée eugène guillaume pour ensuite j'ai
intégré le groupe bâlois donc avec des
formations durant toutes ces années j'ai
fini responsable de maintenance
j'ai envie de transmettre tout ce que
j'ai appris pendant 32 ans d'entreprise
aussi bien les compétences que même le
savoir est parce que le savoir est en
entreprise est très important et quand
je les envoie dans une entreprise et je
leur dis voilà celle là entreprises
j'arrive à cibler les besoins
je sais que s'ils veulent un électricien
mais il faudra que nos élèves
travaillent plus sur ce domaine
au lycée on arrive à personnaliser une
forme c'est à dire qu'en fait vous avez
l'assurance de l'emploi derrière l
expertise de monsieur a passé trente
deux ans dans plusieurs domaines de la
métallurgie à quelle heure il est au
rendez-vous toit et le 10e bain
papaux leur part des îles est pas
question d'être en retard et pio tu me
rends hommage
bonne chance merci pouvoir comme ben
laden ludmilla et vincent se former
trouver un emploi dans un secteur de
pointe sans quitter sa région et bien ce
n'est vraiment pas banale et même si la
tradition ne fait pas tout notre ami
buffon peut être fier un peu plus loin
de montbard et de la métallurgie
d'autres réussissent à bien vivre et
travailler au pays de l'auxois à
flavigny
quand on se balade dans les ruelles de
la petite cité médiévale
on comprend ceux qui veulent y rester
[Musique]
ici dans une ancienne grange
bonjour un groupe d'agricultrices et
d'agriculteurs cuisine et sert des plats
à base de produits locaux et ce1 depuis
près de 40 ans
bonjour c'est le repas du midi qui en
prennent sens du goût des novillos gigot
d'agneau bio de ma ferme de calvaire ben
ouais ouais avec mon conjoint en est
de moutons dans la juste en dessous de
flavigny je lève de moutons et une
cuisine aussi
ouais voilà donc on est plusieurs ici et
en au tour de rôle on vient je viens
trois fois par semaine à peu près et le
reste du temps je vais la faire voilà
pour élever des moutons
ouais comme ça je j'amène mes produits
ici que j'ai élevé
j'ai amené vers les cuisines vous êtes
beaucoup de femmes journée on n'est que
deux mecs en tout cas elle est restée
beaucoup de femmes de déjà en a que deux
missions avec nous je crois qu'elle me
mettais rigaud travail des clips
voilà donc où marie françois que vous
êtes là depuis le début
depuis pratiquement le début c'est une
affaire qui a évolué et que vous avez
vous
évolué et voilà qu'aujourd'hui vous m'en
parlez un peu on se fait un café oui eh
bien on va aller s'installer en cadence
avec pas il fait beau
[Musique]
alors l'origine c'est une histoire de
dame qui était dans leur ferme qui avait
besoin de sortir de chez elle et de
rencontrer d'autres dames pour faire des
choses ensemble entre parenthèses
fleurissement ranger les papiers et
ensuite elles se sont dit oui bah ça va
on va peut-être trouver autre chose
parce que comme on sortait d'une période
de grande sécheresse et qui avait quand
même un besoin que les dames participent
à l'évolution des exploitations
elles sont venues comme ça en pleine rue
proposer des choses des oeufs des
fromages que ce qu'elle avait l'habitude
de faire après ils ont cherché ou ou où
ce même pas d'un lieu ici c'était en
vente mais aucune institution et aucun
marinelli prenait au sérieux
donc il ya un assurance agricole qui a
accepté le jeu et qui a acheté le
bâtiment qui a fait le gros oeuvre
parce que c'était la terre battue la
journée un sol ils ont mis des portes
des finales donc ça s'appelle la grande
similitude cette chaire réellement une
grange et donc elle se soient organisées
à partir de là et ça a commencé en vente
de produits fermiers plutôt que et
s'était ouvert seulement les dimanches
d'été c'est merveilleux ça tu sais tous
âges en toi que c'est une histoire de
femme quoi à l'origine et d'émancipation
de la femme
ado vous êtes deux âmes deux hommes qui
sont venus après son producteur un de
volaille et lui d'escargots et là bas
notre souci premier c'est de faire venir
des jeunes qu'ils soient producteurs et
qui acceptent de venir servir les
clients
et c'est pas facile face il faut aimer
travailler en groupe pour aimer la
clientèle l'idée c'est de transmettre et
d'expliquer qu'ils vous aident quoi des
agriculteurs des producteurs des locaux
qui voulait donner à manger en circuit
court à
le voisin comme celui qui voyage et qui
vient du à points de plus qu on fait
peau neuve
c'est parce que là c'est vraiment de
lagdo ferme à l'assiette du client quoi
là c'est du direct
et oui et comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui pour des escargots sans toi
avec ce beau soleil là ils sont cachés
sous les planches ça va ça se passe bien
mais ce soit grâce aux objets rang que
je leur donne des allemands que je les
arrose puis des fois je travaille au
laboratoire donc je prépare les
escargots
donc ça c'est pour ça qu'on a un
tourneur ici qui nous permet de chacun à
bateaux mais c'est vrai que ça au bout
de la semaine ça représente quand même
un paquet d'heures
mais c'est tellement bon de voir le plan
super satisfait les gens souvent nous
encourage à des partis nous disent qu'on
ne peut vous encourager
moi je vais dégoûté vos produits là
c'est lors de déjeuners donc j'y vais
vous avez gaza l'aide de lentilles on en
a pas aujourd'hui mais on en fait
régulièrement mais c'est dommage ça
contient du fer
[Rires]
oui eh bien moi je pense que c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire tu m'aimes
créer autant d'emplois dans le bassin de
l'auxois je dis chapeau
c'est là c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui
alors voilà nous quittons avec le
sourire qu'ils ont merci encore de votre
fidélité elle me va droit au coeur ne
réchauffe chaque semaine je vous donne
rendez-vous un dimanche prochain je les
embrasse fort
[Musique]